quand et puis ce matin mais c'est en
france cette fois le ministre de
l'environnement faisaient une conférence
de presse c'était sa première il y a
beaucoup parlé de la prévention des
risques industriels
il faut dire que la prévention des
risques nucléaires ne fait toujours pas
partie de ses attributions curieusement
mais les risques industriels sont très
grands en france il y a par exemple 325
site industriel dangereux alors écouter
ce que dit alain carignon à à jérôme
baugnies tout à l'heure et je crois que
le problème du risque industriel du
risque naturel des risques
technologiques sont également importants
dépendent de nos ministères comme il
convient de les prévenir c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai mis en place un
groupe vocal au niveau du ministère du
nom de la catastrophe indienne pour bien
marquer l'importance que j'attache à
cette prévention et quel sera le rôle de
ce groupe il sera de regarder les sites
dangereux de d'imposer un certain nombre
de règles notamment éviter les
constructions à proximité des sites
réputés dangereux de prendre des mesures
de protection et aussi des mesures de
prévention et d'information qui sont
importants et vous avez mis en place
aussi des opérations pilotes dans un
bruit j'ai choisi l'isère parce que je
connais bien l'isère et leurs nobles et
j'ai demandé
haroun tazieff et voit même et à
d'autres voir comment à l'échelle d'un
département nous pouvions bien d'un
million d'habitants mesurer les risques
regardez les mesures concrètes que nous
pouvons prendre et ainsi les ayants
prises et les connaissant peut-être en
faire une expérience utile au plan
national